them to this video saying I am DeMarcus
or that's a high rating how he recently
broke 2600 amazing and over here I had
really bad sky and some wow I don't
really remember these games are like
workshop yes before again interesting
yeah I don't think this is a good a good
decision at all as the pawn on e5 mmm is
weak but still I get this played against
me quite often okay so I think I start
with this first to take the pawn if I
just go here and threatening Knight g6
threatening Knight g6 and pick it up
who does he keep you five routine one is
sir
so 96 and I can we can pick up the pawn
I'm in the pin though doesn't look very
scary I have to take with this
what is it scary here's your Bishop h5
this coefficient h5
I cannot play Bishop d6 then but I can
move the King it's a little bit a little
bit uh pneumonias it's a little bit uh
no - wait the center pond so I've set
the pond as - it's too big to not take
but I have to get I have to be careful
we are the night coming to d6 am
probably go here for Luke the aid it's
always going to be a bit of compensation
for him but again it's a big center born
8k yeah and now I need to try to convert
this pawn 93 looks most obvious jump in
take the pawn here
I wonder if f5 is any good at 596 f4 I
had traps the PISA
it's got Bishop b2 though but okay I can
there are multiple pieces hanging so if
I go f4 now what happens you cannot take
this
I mean Bishop e2 I can move the knight
the bishop has no squares it's protected
twice by the poem by the knight on g6
and by the knight on d3
okay so I just go here okay
so I'm on this piece I have to check
though how to win now Bishop f3 I have
95 okay I'm thinking I should do this go
on to his pawns can take this was chick
I can't take with the knife and then
that's night b3 which is a little bit
odd castle I'll take him
and now yeah probably
head towards b2 so good it's a good
square it's all nicely protected so I
can take him and should be able to pick
up pawns
yeah he can try to get to to here to g7
[Music]
if I check him here we have to go to g1
my tape I can take just this nada not a
big deal ready jack time morning check
you cannot go to h3 and here check click
with check now we are probably get this
back and now March the a poem check
check Oh
didn't see the check okay
a bit slow here how to do this easily 97
no landis upon going in with the King
problem so what I'm trying to do 18
seconds that's going to be tricky anyway
I still got some pawns
maybe I should good night evil one
threatening this and pawn would be nice
to get check rid of this pawn so that I
don't turn possibly lose on time okay
I've Knight c4 if he takes it okay okay
so now I have something that is
extremely easy to play at least check I
need to get rid of the porn otherwise I
might lose it on time I cannot win
anymore than memory stupid yeah but I
didn't didn't win this very easy
technical stuff again okay
I'm too slow I'm too slowly I'm in here
but at 40 seconds or so I should easily
win the whole game was very very one
side
it yeah I have bad bad bad
he had to say was a little bit irritated
by a Skype chat but that's no excuse
anyway so yeah I was basically winning
out of the opening here because he made
a couple of care decisions we should be
551 just blonde a c5 basically the whole
thing um yeah with good technical blame
like should win I mean check this this
was okay what I did okay
I don't even think I made many mistakes
though just just took too long I've got
two minutes here
I should just speed up okay now you can
bring the piece with natural for now
again again sorry I was a bit irritated
and upset because of something else but
I should still win this thing Chang okay
how much to look at I mean it is a is a
complete wind I just I'm just too slow
okay guys thanks for watching